depuis quelques jours un reportage de 7
à 8 passait plutôt inaperçu au moment de
sa diffusion en 2020 fait désormais le
buzz l'émission met en lumière une
prison en Dordogne qui abrite des
délinquants sexuels et qui revendiquent
des méthodes plutôt particulières ils
ont la possibilité de fermer leur
cellules comme il ferme comme on
fermerait notre porte chez nous dans le
reportage de TF1 on aperçoit des détenus
en train de jouer à la pétanque et de
travailler de cuisiner et même de partir
en randonnée ressorti sur les réseaux
sociaux l'extrait a été visionné plus de
5 millions de fois sur Twitter et à
provoquer la colère des internautes elle
est belle la justice française j'ai
envie de chialer ça me dégoûte vraiment
prison spécial pour agresseur sexuel
comprenez-vous que cet établissement
puisse exister
alors merci Karl Zero d'être avec nous
qui est sorti là bien sûr l'envers et ça
c'est très super
laisse-moi 2 minutes car laisse-moi deux
minutes bon merci d'être là en tout cas
merci mais c'est un plaisir et merci de
m'inviter parce que tu sais que les
médias officiels comme toi il y en a pas
beaucoup qui m'invite non c'est vrai
pourquoi ils ont un peu les fois quoi
moi je vais te dire moi et je te le dis
moi pour moi ta révolutionné l'interview
je t'ai toujours regardé voilà c'est je
trouve que voilà c'était un exemple pour
moi tu as toujours été un exemple
politique
vous êtes resté journaliste vous sortez
des affaires non bravo le magazine il
est génial franchement je n'ai pas du
petit lait merci il faut que les autres
t'invites en fait il n'aime pas la
qualité c'est leur problème euh un
reportage de discussion sur les prisons
donc
ressurgit est-ce que tu peux nous
raconter ça pour nous noter les
spectateurs parce que c'est incroyable
quand j'ai dit les conditions quand j'ai
cité des conditions il y a un instant
déjà ils sont sortis ces personnages
sont sortis des prisons normal parce
qu'on a peur que elle se fasse agressive
quand ils arrivent en prison c'est des
pointeurs c'est ça donc ils sont
défoncés à différents endroits du corps
par les prisonniers pour payer ce qu'ils
ont fait parce que les autres
prisonniers ont évidemment des enfants
et vois ça dans le mauvais œil sur une
grande différence entre un braqueur et
un pédocrinel il y a une hiérarchie
voilà donc pour échapper à ça bah on a
créé cette espèce de centre de détention
de Mozac où on les met tous ensemble
mais ça devient libre aux enfants de
summery les mecs font ce qu'ils veulent
c'est ça c'est accoucher dehors alors
déjà on est face à une justice qui est
bien souvent on l'a vu encore avec le
lamentable juge de Dijon qui mettait sa
fille en vente sur Internet
pour que des pédocrinels puissent en
abuser le mec a pris d'abord un an de
sursis un enferme puis en appel 200 avec
sursis donc ça veut dire que soit tu te
retrouves à faire le beau au pays des
Playmobil c'est les Télétubbies ou alors
du sursis et pendant ce temps-là faut
quand même pas oublier que Priscilla
magani la femme qui est je sais pas si
tu as suivi cette affaire là Priscilla
elle s'est pris deux ans ferme et 9 mois
ferme on appelle elle avait pris 5 ans
et qu'est-ce qu'elle a fait elle a juste
emmené sa petite pour en Suisse pendant
11 ans et il s'est fait choper un banal
control routier et lundi on va avoir un
Adam Stockholm qui va repasser à son
tour c'est la même histoire elle son
mari est parti il y a trois ans ils ont
été confiés par la justice à son mari
qui est marin à Tahiti et elle elle
risque un an de prison ferme et elle
elle sera pas à jouer aux boules avec
ses Guignols donc on a pure problèmes
mais fait deux ans que je le dis surtout
enfin 20 ans que je le dis surtout les
dons on a un problème en France avec la
pédocriminalité on sait pas en quoi
quand en faire on sait pas les soigner
c'est l'inanité absolue et quand on
essaye d'aller parler aux gens
responsables soi-disant c'est-à-dire au
gouvernement il nous écoute pas ou alors
ils nous disons
pas qui c'est tout vraiment c'est vrai
que il s'agit jamais à qui ça peut
toucher vraiment donc ils sont toujours
très très emmerdés les médias pareil les
journalistes pareil et donc on a
l'impression de crier un peu dans le
désert mais en même temps on est en
train d'ouvrir un front un vrai froid
bouger
est-ce qu'on est favorable vous
comprenez alors Gilles Verdez comprend
oui alors attention je n'ai pas du tout
aimé le reportage parce que dans le
reportage on va pas le voir là donc
voilà on ne parle pas des victimes etc
mais sur le fait qu'il soit regroupés je
suis favorable parce que c'est la seule
solution pour qu'il prenne conscience
avec des psychiatres adaptés connaissant
connaissance qu'ils ont et pouvant
éventuellement les soigner parce que le
but c'est d'éviter la récidive quand
elle sortir
on a des photos regardez donc les
détenus ont les clés de leurs cellules
donc ça c'est incroyable
les détenus ont les clés donc ils
rentrent qui sortent de faire un tour
hein
les détenus se font de bons petits plats
sachez-le regardez dans le reportage on
peut aussi voir les détenus se cuisiner
un petit poulet voilà tranquille l'un
des détenus explique même qu'il a tout
ce qu'il faut pour cuisiner poivron
piment on a ce qu'il faut il joue à la
pétanque aussi regardez on peut voir les
détenus jouer à la pétanque est-ce que
vous vous imaginez les parents
deviennent parents tu vois les les les
voilà violeurs de leurs enfants en train
de jouer à la pétanque en train de se
faire des poulets basquaise si on veut
rendre les gens dingue on leur montre ça
voilà c'est ça et il y a de quoi être
dingue
et après on va nous dire nous on veut on
veut une justice trop dur ici après on
va on va avoir un supporter on va avoir
des gens qui vont se plaindre à l'arcom
donc voilà donc c'est c'est compliqué
c'est comme c'est c'est
un espèce de liberté mais dès qu'il y en
a un qui marche normalement on le
regarde bizarrement en ce moment donc
c'est tout le monde marche sur la tête
dès que tu as un mec qui marche
normalement tu regardes bizarrement oui
Delphine en fait là on regarde ces
images c'est la colo en fait c'est ça
et pourquoi pourquoi est-ce que ces gens
qui sont délinquants sexuels sont mieux
traités que effectivement des braqueurs
qui sont dans des dans des prisons
françaises conventionnelles qui sont
effectivement très dures je suis désolé
pour les délinquants sexuels ou les
récidivistes sexuels il faudrait
automatiquement à leur entrée ok Club
Med mais d'abord castration chimique ou
autre je suis désolé et comme ça il y a
plus de sujets
on peut se poser la question mais je
rigole des traitements bien sûr non non
parce qu'en fait parce que il parle de
traitement mais des traitements qui
fonctionnent il y en a pas c'est dur ça
on est on est soumis en fait on dit bon
bah vous devrez aller voir le psy
régulièrement et en vrai ça se termine
une fois par an autour d'un whisky avec
le psy alors toujours pedo bah ouais
toujours pédo et puis au revoir
mais c'est pas plus que ça c'est rien
c'est il y a pas de médicaments donc on
a un problème il y a pas de médicaments
et irrésidivent
qu'est-ce que tu veux faire Béatrice non
seulement c'est un scandale pour les
parents des victimes effectivement de
voir les agresseurs
pour toujours mais en plus c'est
scandaleux par rapport aux Français aux
français actuellement les Français
n'arrivent pas à se nourrir à se
chauffer etc et on voit des criminels
qui sont mis dans des endroits comme ça
logé nourrissent ou un coach sportifs
aussi
et les détenus plus qualifient du moment
de plaisir au moment d'émotion et de
moments d'évasion ils ont quasiment pas
de surveillance
pour les pédophiles ça peut pas être le
Club Med là ils font ce qu'ils veulent
ils ont la télé ils mangent qu'ils
veulent quand ils veulent ils font les
courses ils font des randonnées sans
surveillance où ils passent devant des
écoles c'est n'importe quoi donc non
seulement c'est injuste mais en plus
c'est dangereux parce que dans des
conditions comme ça ils ne comprennent
pas que ce qu'ils ont fait c'est
extrêmement grave
il y a une séquence avec un réseau
Internet ils ont la télé il y a une
séquence surréaliste avec un mec qui est
en train de faire des tartelettes aux
fraises et qui dit bah ouais moi je suis
que finalement c'est comme ça je peux
pas le contrôler le gars sort dans deux
ans
ils ont pas de portable en prison
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il regarde sur
leur portable attention
c'est une machine à fabriquer de la
colère vous voyez bien qu'on est tous en
colère alors truc qui Gaspa quoi il y a
la directrice de la prison qui avait
donné une interview il y a quelques
temps il expliquait un peu le
fonctionnement cet endroit regardez
c'était une volonté de se démarquer de
ce qui a existait et de travailler sur
la socialisation et la
responsabilisation des gens et vous avez
une cuisinière une machine à laver
de quoi faire des repas de quoi prendre
les repas en commun ils ont la
possibilité de fermer leurs cellules
comme il ferme comme on fermerait notre
porte chez nous quand il fait beau il y
a certains personnes âgées qui sont sur
la pétanque ils peuvent avoir accès à la
salle de peinture ils vont au gymnase la
bibliothèque est en accès libre aussi
les salles de classe voilà
qui ont fait des voilà comme idée voilà
qui sont quartiers d'autres sécurités
les conditions de vie en prison qui sont
à l'isolement pendant il peut même pas
travailler en prison c'est hyper dur
pour travailler pour avoir le droit de
travailler dans les vrais prisons ça ils
ont le droit de travailler enfin ils
vivent comme presque comme des gens
c'est des prisons à ciel
[Musique]
déjà séparés ils sont déjà un petit peu
mis de côté
ils veulent pas aller avec les autres
parce que ils vont faire ce qu'ils ont
fait aux enfants mais c'est pas eux qui
veulent dire c'est qui qui décide moi je
suis l'administration pénitent
les donner leur avis cet endroit-là
existe parce que qu'est-ce que tu dis au
mec fêter un an fait tes 2 ans et puis
tu pourras commencer tu t'écris un
réseau avec d'autres pédophiles comme
toi et tu pourras retourner à la
pétanque si tu te rattraper si tu te
fais attraper tu pourras refaire ton
cassoulet encore une deuxième fois non
c'est pas comme ça qu'on fait on va on
met pas les mecs comme ça qui viole des
enfants à dire bah c'est pas grave tu as
violé des enfants tu vas pouvoir aller
faire des matchs de foot et des
randonnées en forêt c'est les plus grand
ces gens là c'est la plus grosse
des merdes voilà et tu parlais quoi il y
a pas de peine de mort pour les
pédophiles bah moi je te le redis encore
ici voilà je veux dire encore une fois
ici pour les pédophiles je suis sans
pitié il y a pas de hiérarchie de crimes
quand tu as été là regardez la
hiérarchie stream je suis sans pitié à
partir de quand même un mec à partir de
quand tu les tues
de viol très violent
qui est accusé coupable testament tout
le tralala je le mets pas à jouer à la
pétanque à faire du cassoulet
d'accord avec les autres tu es une
grosse merde et tu iras avec les autres
réfléchissez bien avant de toucher un
enfant vous avez pas volé une voiture
vous avez pas braqué une banque vous
avez touché un enfant je te mets avec
les autres et pas ce qui se passe voilà
pour toi il faut qu'ils aillent dans les
prisons normal et bien sûr le mec comme
nous disait Carl il est dans les prisons
normal forcément ils vont se faire
agresser ils vont se faire taper ça les
réfléchir avant de faire ce qu'ils ont
fait le but de la prison c'est de payer
pour ce qu'on a fait peut-être de se
réinsérer en société pardon mais comment
je n'ai jamais compris alors je n'ai pas
tous les les délinquants et les
criminels dans le même sac là on parle
des pédophiles qu'est-ce qui justifie
qu'un pédophile et sa télé pour garder
tranquillement question pour un champion
tranquillement qu'est-ce qui justifie
qu'un pédophile fasse des poulets
basquaise avec ses potes l'après-midi
qu'est-ce qui justifie qu'un pédophile
fasse des randonnées en dehors la prison
il sort de la prison moi je pense
surtout aux parents et voilà quand il
voit ça bien sûr
tu deviens fou en faisant le mec le mec
tu te dis moi que je vais je vais je
vais je vais je fais plus confiance en
personne en faisant ça on se met du côté
des pédophiles on veut les protéger on
veut prendre leur défense mais c'est eux
les coupables qu'ils aillent en prison
avec tout le monde et s'ils sont
tabassés tant pis pour eux étrange c'est
qu'on entend souvent parler de
QHS quartiers de haute sécurité où on
met des super braqueurs
braqueurs que tu connais car voilà qui
sont maintenant réinsérer il était ils
étaient en quartier d'autres sécurité
ils sont passés
l'équivalent du bagne et en réalité
c'est Aubagne qu'on devrait envoyer les
pédaux un problème c'est que on les
envoie chez les Télétubbies et que la
plupart du temps les envoient nulle part
il y en a trop alors sursis le nombre de
maman protectrices qui voit le père
prédateur voir le qui vont jusqu'au bout
et le mec prend du sursis et il va même
pas en cabane donc c'est là où on a un
énorme problème donc il faut créer
effectivement des départements spéciaux
pour les pédophiles dans les prisons on
a peur qu'ils soient agressés par les
autres toi tu les mettras sur moi écoute
je sais bien que les prisons débordent
et donc si ils prennent deux trois
bandes parce qu'ils ont fait ça en
prison je veux pas aller pleurer non
plus faut pas déconner mais ça serait
mieux de les mettre juste ensemble je
sais qu'à quand c'est le cas à la prison
de camp on en a mis une grande partie
alors là il joue pas aux boules ils sont
comme des prisonniers ils sont entre eux
parce que justement ça déraillettes trop
après ça inquiète la région parce qu'il
y a des mecs quand ils sortent mais ils
sortent tout ils savent de la prison de
quand donc la Normandie tremble un peu
en disant ah merde ils sont là
Jean-Michel la prison certes c'est fait
pour purger une peine mais c'est aussi
pour faire peur c'est qu'on a peur d'un
emprison qui a quel pédophile va avoir
peur sachant que une fois qu'il aurait
commis son crime il va se retrouver dans
une situation peut-être plus heureuse
que la situation il vit actuellement on
vit dans une société où on protège les
les squatteurs
et on chouchoute
c'est nous qui payons on est d'accord
Cyril ça pose la question de pourquoi
tant de l'axisme à l'égard des peaux
criminels il est là le problème de
société bien sûr pourquoi tout le monde
le sait pourquoi personne ne veut bouger
une oreille quoi il faut faire quoi pour
qu'il décide de bouger tu as posé le
problème tout à l'heure en parlant de ce
juge qui vendait sa fille à partir de ce
moment-là on peut se poser des questions
sur les circuits et qui est disons une
certaine compréhension par rapport à ce
genre de cas bien entendu bien entendu
on va pas généraliser bien sûr il y a
des mecs dans toutes les voilà toutes
les corporations
je vais défendre mon point de vue qui
est minoritaire et je
je vais le défendre quand même je ne
veux certainement pas d'un traitement
que le mec comme celui-là mais pour
répondre à Guillaume par exemple qui les
met dans le Guillaume dis-moi je m'en
fous qu'il se fasse défoncer ça c'est de
la folie on ne peut pas répondre à
l'horreur de ses actes pédophiles par
l'horreur d'un pays civilisé qui doit
traiter convenablement c'est détenu quel
qu'il soit ce sont des hommes donc ils
ont ils ont commis
ils ont commis bah non mais c'est mieux
que chez nous il y a des roses partout
tu trouves ça normal enfin on est dans
une résidence presque la résidence
on est ça franchement j'aimerais
payer donner de payer les arbres
si on les met si on les met juste une
seconde carte si on les met avec les
autres même les surveillants disent que
c'est impossible ça me tient dans aucune
raison vous le savez très bien car c'est
impossible donc il faut faire ça en
France on a un problème on ne sait pas
comment les traiter vous me parlez de
castration ça ne marche pas en France on
n'a pas le droit de castrer chimiquement
parce qu'on ne peut pas
être ça ne marche pas la castration
il parle de voter des lois il a raison
mais ça ne marche pas la castration
tu es la France de l'immobilier
franchement je te dis tu es content de
tout
ça
une solution de tout tu l'as aucune
solution
et quelqu'un qui ce bon rapport et des
bonnes infos avec les forces de l'ordre
mais Gilles là excuse-moi mais de te
réveiller en pleine nuit mais tu dis des
conneries mais en vrai tu connais pas
des conneries
tu n'as jamais été en phase de ce genre
de mec tu ne comprends pas à qui tu as
fait des manipulateurs ce sont des
enflures ils vont faire un mois deux
mois six mois un an il ressortent
des hommes non c'est pas des hommes
c'est des monstres et moi je vais même
plus loin alors peut-être voir traiter
moi d'extrême il y a pas de problème je
l'aimais pas dans un prison séparée avec
les autres prisonniers je les mets dans
la prison dans une cellule avec un autre
mec normal
pourquoi quelqu'un qui a perdu son
permis pourquoi un mec qui a fait une
petite bêtise qui a pas un gros
caractère pourquoi lui il reste faire
taper en prison par des plus forts et
pourquoi un pédophile n'irait pas se
faire taper en prison par des trois
c'est comme ça c'est la liberté égalité
fraternité tu vas aller en prison avec
les autres et tu vas te réinsérer avec
les autres et si là-bas tu dérouilles
fallait y penser avant et quand tu vas
sortir tu vas surtout penser à pas le
refaire c'est ça qui m'intéresse c'est
pas
plus je pense pas que ce soit très très
bonne
[Applaudissements]
et toi je suis tombé là-bas qu'est-ce
qu'il va l'empêcher ça j'ai pris il a
pas d'amis dans sa vie il est tout seul
il dit mais après j'ai des amis je vais
aller en promenade en randonnée ils vont
me passer un VTT
non il y a rien qui va l'empêcher de
refaire
Ivan avec tout le monde voilà là il faut
pas pleurer en saisie ils vont entendre
avec tout le monde il se prend des
mandats et c'est tout et il va réfléchir
c'est tout et tu vois que la loi en
prison est beaucoup plus ferme que à
l'extérieur pour tout le monde le mec a
perdu son permis comme dans le reportage
là on a vu la dame qui parlait qui est
donc la directrice de la prison est
content que c'est littéralement une
rencontre crèche elle est totalement à
côté de Pierre elle est fière c'est 30
ans non mais ça c'est le résultat de 30
ans de conneries psycho mes couilles qui
qui font que sont du genre normaux
finalement on peut les insérer on est
tous frères mais c'est pas vrai quoi
c'est pas ce genre de personne
gérer des prisons pour pédophiles oui
elle dit contrairement aux autres nous
les traitent bien tu vois elle est
contente
vous ne pouvez pas Raymond répondre à la
barbarie par la barbarie
j'ai envie de dire à Jules bienvenue
dans la vie tu vois et c'est vrai que en
prison
quelle expérience
je dis simplement que nous sommes et je
m'en félicite un pays civilisé ou la
justice est rendue quand la justice
[Applaudissements]
les amis attention il est en train de
déraper humoriste
je ne vous parle pas de ce reportage et
vous pouvez et vous pouvez non non non
non pas du reportage on parle
globalement
on ne peut pas on ne peut pas on ne peut
pas répondre à des actes monstrueux
commis par ces gens-là qui ne sont pas
des monstres mais qui ont commis des
actes monstrueux pas par le fait de les
faire tabasser en prison on ne parle pas
si vous
[Musique]
vous avez dit ça ouais mais si vous avez
pas le courage
et qui lui arrive qui lui arrive ce sera
tant pis j'ai pas dit qu'il fallait
mettre pour t'avoir mais les
surveillants disent que c'est pas
possible
en prison arrêtez les pauvre
surveillance
ça peut pas être une boucherie en prison
Raymond merci c'est ce que vous voulez
ça va quand je pense moi je pense aux
autres détenus et il y en a beaucoup qui
nous regardent d'ailleurs et qui sont
qui sont eux dans les commentaires
ils deviennent fou voilà les gars voilà
j'ai envie il y en a plein qui ont envie
de sourire série qui ont fait une
connerie qui a envie de repartir et et
qui ont pas qui sont pas des pédophiles
et qui nous regardent c'est souvent le
soir on est d'ailleurs leur fille rayon
de soleil il y en a plein qui m'écrivent
des des bisous et c'est vrai que voilà
quand il voit ça eux ils doivent se dire
mais c'est quoi oui
je vais avoir par la par la perversité
des pédophiles qui sont des grands
manipulateurs t'inquiète pas ils savent
exactement comment se comporter il faut
quand il faut faire les détenus modèles
pour sortir avant ils le font ils
pleurniche pour se faire transférer dans
des établissements comme ça et quand il
justifient leurs actes il y a quand même
un mec qui dit ah j'étais bourré un soir
puis j'ai merdé non tu n'as pas merdé
mais tu as bousillé la vie d'une petite
fille ou d'un petit garçon à vie et
quand tu as mis ce ne sont pas des Mons
ce sont des hommes moi ici ce sont pas
des hommes ce sont des merdes ces mecs
là c'est des grosses merdes et plusieurs
fois
n'oublions pas car un enfant violet
un enfant violet Gilles je le dis pour
toi il prend perpète à vie famille
alors que ce qu'on en a à [ __ ] de ces
[ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
Gilles en fait il est dans la vérité
c'est lui qui est dans non mais j'en
sais rien mais c'est pas l'opinion
majoritaire mais un jour il sortiront
donc il faut tout faire
problème c'est ça le problème si vous
pouvez pas les maintenir toute leur vie
en prison
et c'est ça qu'on doit changer quoi
présentative toute leur vie en prison à
pédophile monsieur
il y a des proportions dans la santé
malheureusement il y a des proportions
dans la santé
15 ans il y a un problème
a pris perpète ok je réponds à tes 15
ans
il y a une grande différence toute leur
vie moi c'est même pire moi oui bien sûr
j'ai pas envie de les nourrir
j'ai pas envie de les nourrir qu'est-ce
que tu veux dire ne m'intéresse pas je
veux pas payer des impôts toute ma vie
on s'en fout les conditions l'essentiel
c'est qu'il récidive pas mais tu crois
que c'est ces conditions je me fous
aussi
justement tu sais le principe le
principe de diviser pour mieux régner si
ces gens disséminées déjà dans une prise
en conventionnelle ils auront peur de
raconter ce qu'ils ont fait mais ici sur
ces bancs fleuries quand ils sont
ensemble je crois ils parlent ils
parlent de leurs expériences et pire du
coup c'est un nid de pédophile et se
crée des réseaux pour la suite la
réinsertion c'est impossible il faut pas
les laisser ensemble ils se renforcent
je suis d'accord avec tout ce que vous
avez dit c'est abominable c'est
insupportable et moi je suis plus dans
votre optique c'est à dire avoir une
prison uniquement pour ces pédocrinels
et que ce soit le bac Cayenne soit un
espace monstrueusement dur et après
vraiment horrible pour ces monstres mais
en revanche
pas on les enferme on les enferme à
double
moi je donne pas de deuxième chance un
pédophile
je donne une deuxième chance à tout le
monde sauf un pédophile je donne pas 2e
chance
moi je moi je pense qu'il doit il doit
être en prison
après tout il leur a mérité et sauf que
imagine il crève et alors non mais et
alors il y en a qui il y en a qui
peuvent crever mais il y en a déjà
faibles ils se retrouvent à la prison
de pédophilie et c'est pour ça qu'il
faut pas qu'il crève parce qu'on fait
des enquêtes sur les réseaux de
pédophile
avait été pendant tué par des dès le
départ de sa première enfin
incarcération on est d'accord qu'on
n'aurait pas remonté toute la chaîne des
victimes qu'il a tué et qu'il a violé on
est d'accord bien sûr donc heureusement
qu'on l'a pas tué heureusement qu'en
prison il a pas été assassiné par un
autre détenu même si c'est un monstre
Immo on dirait l'époque maintenant
heureusement qu'il y a pas eu de peine
de mort pour fournirai ça a permis
d'aller merci loin voilà
par exemple si tu as un coup parce qu'on
l'avait parce que c'est un un gros porc
et c'est tout ce que tous ceux qu'on
voudrait
on peut se poser la question quand tu
penses à l'hollandais que le Landais a
le droit par exemple d'avoir des
relations sexuelles dans sa cellule qui
s'est produit récemment à la surprise
générale donc ça veut dire que le gars
est plus ou moins protégé
si elle a la peine de mort parce qu'il
par rapport à ce qu'il a fait par
exemple par rapport à la petite Maëlys
et peut-être qu'il en a tué d'autres
qu'est-ce qu'on fait donc c'est pour ça
que si il y a pas la peine de mort tu
dis soit de celui qui a envie de passer
à l'acte que ce sera il aura le droit
qu'à une chance non pas 2e
perpétuité mais pas la peine de mort
parce que moi je veux véritable prison
si le fournirait avait été tué dans son
premier passage en prison on aurait pas
montré les autres il y aurait pas eu
d'autres enfants morts sur il sera pas
sortis il y en a eu 12 ou 13 il aurait
eu des victimes il avait déjà fait
malheureuse
c'est pas depuis qu'il est en prison qui
qui peut dire oui parce que en prison
n'en commet plus mais concernant le
Landais on sait pertinemment il y avait
une enquête créée par les gendarmes
c'est lui l'Ariane 55 personnes tuées
dans un premier temps ensuite 14 et
finalement ils ont dit ah ben non plus
aucun donc il y a juste caporal noyer et
Maëlys où sont passés les 14 les 14
autres mystères absolu
il faut pas qu'il soit mort puisqu'on en
parle moi je reste très dubitatif sur la
pédophilie de l'hollandais pour moi ça
reste pas une histoire de pédophilie
c'est une sorte de Cyrielle killer et
c'est une histoire d'enlèvement voilà ce
que je pense mais je l'ai dit 100 fois
la petite Maëlys correspond pas du tout
à ses goûts ces goûts ces crimes ce sont
de jeunes hommes ça n'a rien à voir donc
alors on a dit oui mais il a il a
agressé ses petites c'est vrai il a fait
des photos de ces petits nièces endormi
en baissant leur culottes avec son
portable qu'est-ce qu'il voulait en
faire et vendre s'amuser c'est pas pour
moi c'est pas un prédateur pour moi
c'est un enlèvement qui tourne mal il
lui met une claque la petite cri dans la
voiture il met une claque la claque de
trop elle meurt voilà mais on m'a pas
prouvé et on m'a pas expliqué pourquoi
les gendarmerie avait brûlé pourtant là
il fait dans l'envers des affaires on a
posé les questions pourquoi cette
gendarmerie il y avait toutes les pièces
concernant l'affaire Maëlys brûle qu'un
jour après entièrement et on dit ah
c'est
le groupe anarchiste en cherchant encore
bon on va pas revenir ça rejoint un peu
ce qu'on disait
toujours le côté
que ça touche à ça ah non non non ça
existe pas pendant 20 ans moi je me suis
pris mais tout dans la gueule sur le
thème les réseaux n'existent pas dans
les gens commencent à mettre oui on
envisage un peu les crimes rituels
n'existaient pas ah depuis qu'il y a eu
le la ah c'est vrai que c'est un peu un
crime rituel quand même sinon pourquoi 0
et 1 sur les pieds c'est vrai que c'est
bizarre bon et petit à petit on y arrive
mais je pensais pas que la lutte serait
aussi longue j'ai l'impression de ça
fait 20 ans
mais moi je vous le redis série quand
vous donnez votre avis sur perpétuité
pour les pédophiles ou quand Raymond dit
moi je les nourris même pas je vais
encore vous choquer mais même s'ils sont
pédophiles ce sont pas des mots ce sont
des hommes donc le but ben oui mais
c'est non oui mais c'est ce qui c'est
qui c'est ce qui est fondamentalement
nous oppose d'accord c'est que le but
c'est qu'il ne commence pas et moi je
pense que quand ils sont ensemble quand
ils sont ensemble ils peuvent prendre
conscience de l'horreur
[Applaudissements]
réfléchissez bien imaginez qu'il arrive
quelque chose à votre fille est-ce que
vous tiendrez les mêmes
proposez
exactement la même chose
d'être con comme une pine voilà
[Applaudissements]
j'ai le droit d'avoir son avis il y a
plein qui pense comme dit les sons pas
cons c'est voilà c'est un débat c'est un
débat
il y en a qui pensent comme Gilles et
Gilles voilà il est pas posé aussi
ce mec là il joue à la pétanque
est-ce que tu serais contente qu'ils
soient content qu'on lui donne à manger
les gens mourraient à Cayenne les gens
mouraient à Cayenne
un pédophile un pédophile toi pour toi
tu l'envoies pas mourir en prison non
bah non c'est le permis bateau pour
qu'il s'amuse un peu tu vois
c'est mieux
ah oui on va faire abstrait facile la
vraie question elle est là c'est vrai
que c'est non je ne l'envoie pas mais
c'est son avis
c'est facile mais ok mais je vous répond
clairement NON je vais pas mourir en
prison je pense qu'il faut améliorer en
France on est nul avec la la le
traitement de la pédophilie il faut
mettre des moyens on est nul partout
mais tu veux rien faire mais si je veux
mais non tu veux continuer je veux des
solutions je veux des traitements je
veux des psy mais
la psychiatrique il n'y a pas de
traitement le temps de récidive des
pédophiles est plus faible que celui des
députés
non non
viable on peut les inviter à voir à
faire une sorte de psychothérapie pour
les calmer on peut leur donner des
calmants pour leur donner la castration
chimique n'existe pas réellement à
l'existence un peu dans certains pays du
Canada elle existe ouais mais elle a pas
elle fait pas des preuves fantastique et
donc on sait qu'on a un vrai problème
avec ces personnes là parce qu'elles
vont recommencer parce que c'est leur
truc c'est leur truc donc si tu les
isole pas et pas au pays des Télétubbies
mais si tu les isole pas dans un truc
dur ou ils ont pas peur à quoi ça change
alors un truc dur à quoi ça change rien
je risque lourd bien sûr là il risque
rien sûr bien sûr 15 ans là
pourquoi les pouvoirs publics selon vous
ne bouge pas plus sur cette question là
autant sur le niveau de l'incarcération
que sur les lois qui punissent plus
s'énerver parce que depuis 30 ans c'est
la patate chaude qui sont emmerdés parce
qu'il y a des gens importants qui en
croque et voilà c'est tout à dire qu'ils
sont qui ont des tendances pédophiles
tout le monde décollerait on cite leur
maman
et le problème c'est que ça bloque
entièrement un système en France
on est là pour faire péter ce [ __ ]
incroyable et protéger les gosses mais
c'est c'est que ça c'est que ça
l'essentiel parce que le milieu
politique est impliqué
[ __ ] magistrat certains élus certains
élus certains politiques
qui sont là
tu as la preuve qui a des réseaux
pédophiles qui couvriraient des actions
est-ce que je prends
évidemment dans la limite de la
diffamation et que ça c'est
intelligemment fait mais on te raconte
point par point pourquoi telle histoire
elle va pas avancer du tout ah le mec
non on parlait du mec de Dijon le mec de
Dijon [ __ ] il prend un an des juges ça
te monte au cerveau tu as une fille de
15 ans de 14 ans tu la vends sur
internet non tu la vends pas bon lui ça
lui monte au cerveau le mec il prend un
an et un enferme et un un sursis il fait
appel oh je fais appel devant un sursis
il est libre
dont tu parles mais c'est pas une
justice ils ont ils ont le feu au cul de
cette histoire Bernard changer tout non
il a raison car le seul problème je
crois que on parle tu disais ça fait
peur il faut leur faire peur il faut les
heures des trucs durs tu as raison on a
envie de ça sauf que ce sont des
pulsions et que même s'ils vivent des
moments très durs en prison
il y a du déni ils ne peuvent pas lutter
donc pour toi pourtant on les laisse on
les laisse avis en prison pour toi ah
vie en prison alors la prison la plus
dure du monde ah oui il reste voilà
c'est ça on va on va voir juste qu'on
pensait des spectateurs euh voilà nous
moi 92 % bien sûr voilà les c'est dingue
parce que quand on paye des anges tout
le monde est pratiquement d'accord et
rien ne bouge derrière tu comprends pas
c'est un truc de fouet
que ça se passe pas est-ce que je peux
témoigner d'une chose je vais témoigner
d'une chose sans citer de nom il m'est
arrivé un jour d'être un déjeuner avec
des officiers supérieurs de gendarmerie
des généraux il y avait un journaliste
qui enquêtait sur des choses très très
difficiles et ce journaliste on
discutait parce que j'étais là j'étais
invité je parlais avec tous ces bons
mondes et journaliste on a cité
plusieurs hommes politiques des élus
politiques très très en vue et le
journaliste parlait et les gendarmes ont
dit on a les dossiers on attend
simplement qu'on nous donne l'ordre
parce que les gens qui étaient cités
étaient des gens de réseaux des gens qui
feront tout pour que jamais les systèmes
ne changent au profit de la Société pour
protéger alors il y a les excuses dont
tu parles maintenant et il y en aura
d'autres on va dire c'est des complots
c'est pas des complots ce sont des
réalités qui existent malheureusement
depuis toujours et c'est très difficile
de pouvoir dire on va tout changer qu'on
le veuille c'est une chose mais si tu es
les gens qui sont très hauts qui
tiennent les autres tu sais je me tiens
tu me tiens par la barbichette il y en a
un paquet si il a parfaitement résumé la
situation c'est exactement ça sauf que
là où tu te trompes mon cher Daniel que
je me trompe quelquefois et souvent même
alors là où tu te trompes c'est qu'on va
réussir à faire changer les choses
je te le souhaite je te le souhaite de
contemporaine bouger les choses on va
rien faire parce qu'on est extrêmement
nombreux